hello everyone this game was played in
1964 between English Grandmaster Raymond
Keene and the person named fielder and I
couldn't really find any information on
mr. fielder nor a photo of him
hence the hoodie guy again and this is
the second game by Raymond keen I'm
throwing on my channel the first one was
that loss against Hans Joaquim Hecht
called heck's little immortal or what
the heck it's also a fun game if you
want to check it out
but this game mr. Raymond also shows
that he himself can also play a little
immortal game so let's see this beauty
Raymond has the white pieces and mr.
fielder has the black pieces and
although I couldn't find any information
on mr. fielder I did find out that he
was a composer of weird chess problems
and he was awarded for his compositions
so okay Raymond goes d4 and we have nice
to see 6a Knight to f3 d6 d4 and Bishop
to g4 the game transposes into the names
of each defense we have d5 Knight to e5
and this is this is the critical
position of the game already unmoved a 5
I had this position a lot of times in my
blood sample of games sometimes going
for Bishop e2 sometimes for Bishop b5
check sometimes I played Knight to c3
depending depending on the mood really
but Raymond's idea really deserves
attention here Raymond played Knight
captures on e5 already on move 5
sacrificing his queen and it's not
really it's not that white has a force
checkmate on it or anything it's it's
just an interesting idea and Raymond
went for it
so ok Bishop capture Sundy one fielder
accepts the Queen sacrifice and we have
Bishop to b5 check and well unless you
want to lose your queen here with Queen
37 only movies upon the c6 not blocking
check we have D captures on c6 now
Raymond is threatening C capture some b7
which check winning the rook and also
getting a queen of his own and we have
Queen to a5 check Knight to c3 by
Raymond you can't capture the bishop on
d1 if King Carter Sundy wand and Queen
capture some beef
five and this is completely winning for
black so after a queen to f5 check
Raymond goes for Knight to c3 now
defending the bishop on b5 and well this
is again the critical moment in the game
mr. fielder played B captures on c6 and
well this was this was the last moment
that like could get back into the game
the correct move here is actually a six
and it looks weird playing this a six
move because white is threatening C
capture some b7 checking the King
winning the rook and also getting a
queen of his own but that's just it this
is impossible for white because if C
capture some b7 would check now a
captures Bishop on b5 there's no more
check and if white captures this rockin
a8 you capture with the Queen now the
Queen is defending the rook this is a
completely winning position for black
but unfortunately filter didn't see this
and after Knight to c3
he played big captures on c6 and now
Raymond takes the initiative
he plays Bishop captures on c6 but check
King to d8 and now I'm not going for the
rook but first Knight captures on f7
forking the King and the other rook on
h8 we have King to c7 and our Bishop
captures on a8 and the fielders the
bishop is still attacked on d1 so Bishop
to h5 would attempt on the knight and
Knight captures rook on h8 and if you
count the pieces well both players have
three pieces and the arraignment has two
rooks
for this Queen an a5 and also I believe
he's up two points so definitely
materialistically the position is in
White's favor and also positionally I
mean black doesn't really have anything
here white will develop the bishop
castle and well it will be perfectly
fine for Raymond so how does what
continue here he plays east six he
doesn't allow this Bishop to get away
from a8 with Bishop to d5 Raymond
castles and we have Queen to b6 and now
preparing
Queen to be eight winning this Bishop on
a eight but Raymond has another trick up
his sleeve he plays fifa
making room for this bishop so now the
bishop can escape with E 4 or F 3
fielder stops this he was for d5
but this D 5 move doesn't really do
anything for black as Raymond simply
captures the pawn Bishop captures on d5
and you can't capture the bishop if you
go e capture 75 will be at night to
capture Sun d5 for King the king and the
Queen so after Bishop captures on d5 a
filter goes for Bishop to b4 now
attacking this Knight that is
threatening to fork the king and queen
and the Bishop d3 by Raymond but a
temple on the Queen Queen to a5 and
Bishop captures on e6 and well this is a
completely winning position for white
there really isn't a good move for black
but well black captures the pawn on e5
maybe he saw what Raymond's move will be
but as I said he is a composer of weird
chess problems so he might have done
this on purpose who knows
he played Queen captures on e5 allowing
Raymond to finish the game in great
style
Raymond plays Bishop to f4 now painting
the Queen and well mr. fielder doesn't
even bother to play the strongest move
that his Bishop captures on c3 he
captures the bishop Queen captures on f4
and we have Knights to d5 with a triple
fork checking the King the king and also
attacking the Queen and this Bishop on
b4 and the disposition mr. fielder
resigned the game so yeah definitely a
beautiful game and a beautiful beautiful
beautiful ending picture and yeah I do
hope you enjoyed it a very nice game by
the English Grandmaster Raymond King so
yeah I would like to thank David Kaye
drove ski Sean Callahan Robert figure
and Lucas all for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot I really appreciate
it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank y'all for watching
guys I will see you soon